[Música]
mi nombre es camelo mejías y mi gran
motivación mi gran motivación es chile
chile me encanta chile me encanta
visitar chile su gente recorrerlo andar
en bicicleta caminar correr en chile me
encanta cuando salgo por el mundo en
todos lados hablo de chile de lo grande
que es chile
aunque nadie lo conoce
es un punto que está acá abajo aunque
acá en chile sigo obviamente sabemos
dónde está en un punto que está acá
abajo y para misiles grandiosos tiene
una gente impresionante sabe hacer
muchas cosas es muy muy grande lo que
tenemos acá pero tenemos un gran
problema el problema es que no nos
sabemos comunicar y nos movemos en
círculos diferentes chile se clasifica
en ingenieros científicos humanistas
emprendedores y además le podemos
agregar deportistas y músicos
entonces si tú eres ingeniero tus amigos
son ingenieros tus carretes tus asadhos
son con ingenieros te comunicas con
ellos y hablas de ingeniería todo el día
si eres emprendedor tus amigos son
emprendedores tu comunicación diaria es
con emprendedores no sabemos unirlas
disciplinas y en eso podemos hacer
grandes cosas yo les voy a hablar sobre
dos mundos los cuales me ha tocado
desenvolverme en los últimos años el
primero
el primero es la academia
la academia y bueno aquí tengo que decir
de que yo en realidad soy casi criado y
nacido en la academia mis primeros
recuerdos son elevando volantines en mi
alma máter es que la universidad de
concepción mis navidades todas las
navidades las pasaban recibiendo regalos
dentro de la universidad y entonces nos
fue
y sorpresa para nadie que yo haya
decidido estudiar adentro iii a los 20
años me haya decidido dedicarme a la
investigación me acerca a un profesor y
dije yo yo quiero trabajar en paper
quiero seguir en la academia además que
mi carrera yo soy ingeniero matemático
te dicen si te vas por la academia es un
rockstar te pagamos los viajes los
congresos viaja por el mundo y de muy
bueno si te vas por la industria en
realidad eres malo y no te apoyamos
entonces no es muy muy difícil decidir
la academia y en esto me di cuenta que
somos súper buenos me tocó viajar por
varios lugares me di cuenta que se había
sabiendo mucho acá nos volvemos en
círculos de élite de la academia y somos
bien buenos en eso sin embargo cuando me
tocó irme a otro país a suecia en
particular me tocó estar en una
universidad en lunch una universidad de
350 años de historia con noveles en una
ciudad en la cual se inventó tecnología
que ocupamos día a día por ejemplo
bluetooth las cajitas de leche que toman
todos los días el tetra pak se inventó
allá entonces yo llegué y dije oye qué
puedo hacer yo en esta universidad que
es tan vieja que es tanta historia tanta
tradición que ha tenido o sea que voy a
saber yo de un país que hace 200 años
recién estábamos peleando
para poder ganar independencia de hecho
en esta plaza y empecé a escuchar las
tesis de ingenieros de magíster de
doctorado y me di cuenta oye pero si las
tesis que están haciendo ellos en
exactamente iguales a las que hacemos en
concepción dónde está la dificultad a
veces algunas tesis son más fácil otras
más difíciles pero a veces lo mismo que
en la diferencia de este país que lo
hace tan grande con nosotros que no nos
creemos el cuento y ahí me di cuenta que
la clave no nos creemos el cuento empecé
a investigar como dicen las pantallas
chile es uno es un país con mucha
diversidad en ciencia tanto así que es
comparado con corea del sur la
diversidad nuestras ciencias con ellos
aunque corea sea un país muy
desarrollado mucho más arriba que
nosotros nuestros científicos son
capaces de hacer lo mismo chile tiene
mucha investigación y mucha ciencia pero
lamentablemente queda guardada dentro de
los papers no nos creemos el cuento
creemos que desde concepción al mundo no
somos capaces de hacer nada creemos que
desde chile no tenemos la habilidad de
españa pero la gente acá es capaz hay
que creerse el cuento hay que saber hay
que saber soñar que somos capaces de
hacer cosas mundiales y esa es la gran
diferencia
entre un país evolucionado por decirlo
entre comillas como suecia con nosotros
chile
el otro mundo en el cual me empecé a
mover fue el emprendimiento terminé de
la academia publiqué papers y ahora
estoy trabajando en emprendimiento y en
el emprendimiento también me di cuenta
que somos súper buenos no es que seamos
bueno en todo es que acá somos muy
buenos por ejemplo para la gente de
start-up chile que viene un programa
reconocido a nivel mundial que puede
inculca en cuba' emprendedores mundiales
en chile para poderlo exportar al mundo
si le dice el chile con vale en honor a
silicon valley por supuesto allá en eeuu
somos el chile con valley de sudamérica
tenemos el país con más emprendedores
activos y emprendimientos nuevos en el
mundo según la oecd si ustedes preguntan
en una clase o en un grupo de amigos
quién quiere entender todo el mundo
levanta la mano acá quién quiere
entender a quién le gustaría hacer cosas
a mí me gustaría hace 10 años si
tuvieses preguntado eso dos levantan la
mano y el resto hubiese preferido
trabajar de planta en una empresa
jubilarse en esa empresa y se ha
empleado de oro ahora no es así en chile
todo el mundo tiene ganas de hacer cosas
quiere hacer cosas no porque se quede
forrar de dinero porque tiene ganas de
hacer cosas quiere hacer grandes cosas y
esa es la clave si nosotros nos creemos
el cuento y queremos hacer cosas podemos
hacer grandes cosas
ahora huele el punto
el comienzo decíamos que los científicos
cómo se comunican con científicos
trabajan con científicos son buenos pero
trabajan con científicos y se quedan en
la ciencia donde está la ciencia
lamentablemente son la universidad qué
pasa con los emprendedores hacen
emprendimientos generan muchas cosas y
dónde se quedan en el ecosistema del
emprendimiento y por qué nos unimos los
dos mundos porque nos juntamos la
academia de la ciencia con el
entendimiento porque no solamente
hacemos una plataforma no solamente nos
dedicamos al pinter que es hacer un
marcha entre una y otra persona porque
no hacemos emprendimientos científicos
porque no somos capaces de ser híbridos
si somos híbridos que significa híbridos
híbridos significa juntar dos dos cosas
diferentes y hacer una nueva si somos
capaces de hacer ciencia y
emprendimiento seremos capaces de hacer
grandes cosas y a nivel mundial porque
porque por separado ya no somos somos
muy buenos si hubiésemos sabido hacer
emprendimientos científicos antes nos
hubiésemos ha hecho un software para
poder modelar las avalanchas y cuantas
vías hubiésemos salvado en el pueblo de
santa lucia en la carta de austral
ocupando algo muy parecido cuántas
vídeos hemos salvado en los aluviones
del norte hace un par de años atrás la
ciencia es muy buena el emprendimiento
es muy bueno pero si lo juntamos podemos
hacer cosas grandiosas entonces el
llamado es a hacer estas cosas a creerse
el cuento que desde concepción desde
chile al mundo somos capaces de hacer
grandes cosas es un mensaje a todo chile
a todo sudamérica que nosotros somos
capaces de poder cambiar el mundo
cambiar la humanidad si queremos dejar
huella creas el cuento porque esa es la
manera de poder avanzar que los quiero
dejar con el concepto híbridos mezclen
sus áreas y ustedes son médicos mezclen
se con ingenieros y ustedes son
deportistas mezclan se con la humanidad
tanto más podemos hacer en la humanidad
tenemos dos premios nobeles y cuando
hemos unido las humanidades con la
ingeniería con la ciencia con el
emprendimiento
cuanto más podemos crear si juntamos los
mundos conversan con el que está al lado
crean alianzas salgan recurren reúnanse
y creen nuevas cosas no sigamos haciendo
mundos diferentes dentro un país tan
pequeño como chile según en hecho porque
es una revista de difusión científica
muy grande chile es un laboratorio para
poder hacer ciencia tecnología es un
laboratorio natural de hecho tenemos el
desierto más árido cierto los hielos
glaciares más fríos en el sur pero
ustedes sabían cuando hablan de ok
hablemos de desierto y de sol que pasa
energía solar cierto energía solar o
agarremos tecnología alemana de paneles
solares y pongamos la dentro del norte
de chile- ustedes saben que eso no se
puede no se puede porque la radiación
del norte de chile- es tan fuerte que
derrite los circuitos de los paneles
solares nosotros tenemos que hacer
tecnología chilena para poder
desarrollarla en chile porque nuestro
ecosistema es idóneo para crear nuestras
propias cosas no
a un país afuera made in germany y medio
en china no es lo mejor
nosotros podemos crear acá y tenemos la
gente tenemos el desierto más árido un
sistema súper vulcanológico tenemos un
mar de 4.500 kilómetros de costa cuando
lo aprovechamos donde está la ciencia el
entendimiento con eso crianza el cuento
hagan cosas reúnanse porque chile es
impresionante y podemos hacer cosas de
acá hacia el mundo muchas gracias
[Música]